GBBO S08E02
It's week two in the Bake Off tent.
One baker has already departed,
11 remain.
Another great day of baking ahead.
I've got the flour.
Wow, that's a big bag.
How are you going to get it
out of the wheelbarrow?
Self-raising.
I don't think I've forgotten
anything.  Well, apart from...
BOTH:  Welcome to
the Great British Bake Off!
Do you want a lift?
No, you're all right.
Sure? OK. I'm picking up Prue.
Last time...  Going in.
Let's be brave.  ..the competition
began with some unreal baking.
Wowsers!  Look at that.
Despite Flo and Sophie's
stunning cakes...
Gosh!  ..Steven became this year's
first Star Baker.
This is perfect.
HE SIGHS
And although and Chris
and Stacey stumbled...
Am I going to put it in the bin?
..Peter was the first to leave
the Bake Off tent.
I don't know what to say, mate.
That's all right.
This week...
..it's biscuits...  Ta-dah!
..for the Signature Challenge
that's all about precision...
It's so tough,
it's offering me up for a fight.
..a mind-bending Technical...
Aargh! So frustrating!
..that's an Oriental mystery...
That looks more like
a Cornish pasty.
..and a game-changing biscuit
Showstopper...
This is me stressed.
..that's never been attempted
before.
Ah!  Chin up.
I'm going.  No, you're not!
I mean, the interesting thing
about the word biscuit is it
comes from the Latin for bis,
meaning twice, and coquere, cooked.
Twice cooked, because the original
way in which they made them...
Have you eaten all those biscuits?
I thought I'd do some eating stuff
while you're doing
some speaking stuff.
Wow, you literally take the biscuit.
It's Biscuit Week.
Is there not even a crumb left?
Yeah.
The bakers are about to face
three biscuit-based challenges
over the next two days,
but who will be
our second Star Baker
and who will be the second to have
to leave the Bake Off tent?
Morning, bakers, and welcome
to your Signature Challenge.
Today, Prue and Paul would love you
to make 24 sandwich biscuits.
There should be
two separate biscuits,
neatly sandwiched together, with a
flavoursome filling of your choice
that should compliment
your style of biscuit.
You have two hours and 15 minutes
to make your sandwich biscuits.
On your marks...  Get set...  Bake!
The Signature bake this week is
a devilishly difficult challenge,
I think, because you've got
to make 48 biscuits to
make 24 sandwich biscuits,
so they've got to think of how
they're going to break those
so they're all equally sized and
equally coloured at the same time.
PRUE: One of the risks is that
the filling will be too soft.
When you get it in between
your teeth,
out comes the lemon curd
or the buttercream.
If you combine a hard biscuit
with a soft interior,
it will go all over your lap.
Hello, Liam.  Hello.  Tell us
about your sandwich biscuits.
It's a pecan
and malt flavoured biscuit.
Like at a diner. I always get
a malt and chocolate milkshake.
This sort of reminds me
of the '50s, Back To The Future.
And it's, like, slightly subtle,
but it creeps up.  Yeah.
It's like, "Hello, I'm here.!
Liam began baking just four years
ago, inspired by his mum, Eleanor.
Where is that carrot cake?
Just taste the food, boy.
Sorry.
He's sandwiching coffee
buttercream between pecan
and malt shortbread.
We used to be given malt
cos it was good for us
after the war.
Which, the First World War?
Yeah, First World War.
Such a delicious flavour.
So the whole thing
is going to be crunchy?  Kind of.
It's cookie or is it biscuit?
It's a biscuit.  So it will snap?
So you're looking for
a soft snap, yeah?  Soft snap.
A soft snap...
THEY LAUGH
Whatever texture the bakers
are aiming for...
The softest centre and a bit
of crunch on the outside.
..they can ruin it
when trying to introduce flavour.
225g.
Too many wet or dry additions
to their basic dough now...
..can drastically alter
the bite of their baked biscuit.
This is pistachio extract
that I couldn't find
anywhere in England.
So when I went to Russia last time,
I went to these baking shops,
and I found it there,
which was quite good.
Julia left Siberia to live in
Crawley with her husband, Matt,
and their dog, Ned.
Ned! Ned!
Her pistachio and cardamom
biscuits will sandwich a vanilla
and rose jelly.
Flavours give you
instant memories, don't they?
They remind you of something.
When I bite into them, I think of
Turkey, the time I met my husband.
Aw! Was it very romantic?  It was.
He kind of came up to me
and started chatting me up.  Uh-oh!
Then, literally, we walked
with each other for like two hours,
ended up talking about everything
and nothing.
And you kind of know whether
it's the right person or not,
you kind of feel it.
Do you know, that's marriage -
everything and nothing.
That's exactly
what marriage is like.
Steven's also flavouring
his biscuit dough with a little
holiday romance.
There's some amaretto.
I was in Rome years ago, one
of the fondest memories was sitting,
having a coffee and an amaretti
biscuit, and it was a warm Sunday
morning, so the bells were tolling,
and it was incredibly romantic.
Steven's love of romance
even extends to the music
he listens to as he bakes.
He has lovingly adapted
a classic amaretti dough
recipe for his coffee cream
filled biscuits.
What's gone into this mixture,
then, for the biscuits?
Semolina flour. So, semolina gives
like a softer, chewy texture.
A bit of crunch outside, soft dough,
and then squashy coffee middle.
And then you should have the classic
Italian combination
of amaretti and coffee.
Let's hope they are.
The classic flavours
in Yan's biscuit dough
were born in Enfield, North London.
I'm making peanut butter.
But they're no less romantic.
It's based on something my wife
likes to eat
after she goes to Zumba.
Usually she has peanut butter
and banana on toast.
Yan met her wife, Marianne,
at the local football club,
and they've been together
for 16 years.
Her peanut butter cookies will have
a banana cream filling and she
has another one of her scientific
tricks up her sleeve.
I'm going to roll it caster sugar,
so when it bakes, it will rise.
And then when you take it out,
it will fall
and it'll have a nice crack on it.
Puts muscles on you, this.
Gets rid of your bingo wings.
There's me dough done.
And just put it in the fridge.
Unless the dough is chilled
until it's firm,
when it comes to cutting
and shaping,
producing 48 identical biscuits
will be impossible.
I'm happy.  But before
they can start chilling...
We are looking for uniformity,
don't forget.  ..Steven,
James...  Here we go.  ..and Tom...
They're going to go in the freezer
just for two minutes.  ..have given
themselves even more work to do.
You need to chill them
so they hold their shape.
If you put them in the warm oven,
they just seep away.
They're hand piping and then
chilling every single biscuit.
I'm not very good at getting
everything the same size,
so I've put a little template
underneath to give me a rough guide.
Accuracy is vital in James's work
as a finance project manager,
but things got a little less
precise
when he's teaching his sons
Ollie and Ethan how to bake.
THEY LAUGH
His piped dough will be the basis
of his take on a Viennese whirl,
crossed with his favourite
pudding - rhubarb and custard.
Following the feedback last week,
presentation is going to be key
this week.
Going in the fridge.  No problem.
To perfect his presentation,
Tom is having to work his piping bag
twice as hard.  Just piping
the base of the biscuits now.
They are different to the top
because they are going to be flat
instead of fluted.
I do have quite a steady hand
because, with work,
I have to draw quite fine things.
But when you're in here,
the nerves do affect that slightly.
Tom's keen architectural eye
will see him
plan his bakes in almost
as much detail as his buildings.
His time-consuming design
features two contrasting
piped coffee biscuits
filled with alternating coffee
and amaretto buttercream.
They all have to be identical,
so I need 48 biscuits
and I'm going to make 70,
just so I've got a few spare ones.
And I've already done
four really messily,
which I've had to scrape off
and redo.
But that's fine, I've got time.
Whilst her dough is in the fridge,
Flo gas begun preparing her filling.
This is my raspberry stewing
in raspberry gin.
You can get drunk on this!
At 71, Flo and all her girlfriends
still meet up for a few cocktails.
# I'm all about the base
about the base, no treble. #
Her gin jam and vanilla buttercream
will fill two shortbread
biscuits shaped like
slices of bread.
Do you think you'll have any gin
flavour at all, though?
If you've boiled it with the jam,
you've lost all the alcohol.
I put a bit in the buttercream.
Ah! Clever girl.
A bit of booze where we know
we can taste it.
Gin always makes me a bit weepy.
Am I going to be crying
when I eat this?  No. I hope not!
And Flo's not the only one
who's turned to drink.
Adding my whisky. Just gives it
the most incredible flavours.
Chris's love of fine whisky
is matched
only by his passion
for the high seas.
Perfect job.
His whisky and orange filling
will sit between chocolate biscuits
made with chia seed
and even more whisky.
We know you're good with flavour
already, we've learned that.
So, you're going to bite in,
taste the chocolate,
then the hit of the whisky,
then you get this lovely finish
of a bit of orange afterwards.
There's a lot of flavours in there,
but they do all go together,
don't they?
Well, it's not, like, in your face,
your eyes watering whisky,
but you get this whisky.
I've got one question for you...
Can I have your shirt?
As long as I don't have to have
you on with your spandex again, yes.
THEY LAUGH
Sophie is also hoping to blow
the judges away
with an adults-only filling.
I've just come back from Italy,
Just teaching military
personnel how to ski.
I drank lots of limoncello,
still have some of it.
Didn't drink it all.
Since leaving the Army,
Sophie has also begun training
to be a stuntwoman.
For a real lemon kick,
her curd filling will have a large
double shot of limoncello.
I have to put a lot in
to get any of the flavour.
But it does mean that it
doesn't set very well.
The judges will be looking
for a filling that won't ooze
out when the biscuit is eaten.
If I add too much banana,
it becomes very wet,
but I want the flavour
to come through.
But whilst most of the bakers
are looking to stiffen things up...
This is the rose water jelly.
We need it to set.
..Stacey is aiming for something
a little softer.
Marshmallow fluff,
my kids' favourite.
I came down for breakfast yesterday
and the jar was open...
and a massive scoop taken out of it.
The morning routine at Stacey's
house...  Thanks, Mum.
..is usually too hectic
for treats at breakfast.
Love you.  Thanks, Mum,
I love you, bye.
Her marshmallow fluff will sit
between chewy chocolate cookies,
dusted with edible glitter.
I'm not quite sure I want that
metallic flavour in my mouth.
There isn't any flavour.  Taste
the bling, Paul.
It's just to look good.  Do you like
a bit of bling?  Yes.  Don't you?
Cos you made a sort of
designer handbag.
I haven't any girls in my life,
so I like to, where I can,
put a bit of glitter in.
But now Paul has worried me if I've
got too much glitter.
We'll see.  Good luck.
He likes to put the fear
of God in you, doesn't he?
What are you doing?
Making a sandwich biscuit.
Yeah, I don't think you've
completely got the hang of it.
Baker s, you are halfway through
the time for your sandwich biscuit.
Do you want a bite?
Yeah, thanks.
MUMBLES: Mm! Delicious. Mm!
I know.
Just taking this out of the fridge
and just rolling it out now.
These are just little dowel rods
I usually use
to support stacked cakes,
and they're just a nice guide.
The judges will expect every single
biscuit to be identical in thickness
and shape.
Make sure I weigh it precise.
As long as I have it round, gravity,
science will take care of it.
They probably won't be completely
identical. I'm not a magician.
I feel like the thickness
has to be perfect.
I kind of wanted to be, like,
just under a centimetre,
like more biscuit than filling.
Because I love a little biscuit.
I'm happy with that.  To cut perfect
shapes from their biscuit dough...
I didn't want to do anything
too simplistic.
..Kate and Flo
have been improvising.
You have to be good
at arts and crafts
when you come to the Bake Off.
Not just baking,
it's making things like this.
A corned beef tin.
I'm quite proud of that.
I adapted a round mould
and I put it in a bench vice,
and then shaped it
into a shell shape.
The shell shape is used in quite
a lot of Edwardian designing.
Kate also satisfies her passion
for history by restoring antique
furniture.
And it's a fascination
with family history that's led
to an ambitious, highly decorated
coconut biscuit, filled with
coconut-rum cream
and pineapple curd.
Rum, coconut and pineapple,
that's a pirate's biscuit.
Yeah.  Is that what you're going
for?  It is Titanic-themed.
When I researched into recipes
on board the Titanic,
coconut sandwich biscuits were
actually served for afternoon tea.
And I had a relative on board.
And he survived, actually.
He was a passenger, was he?
No, he was engine room.
Engine room, and he got out?  Yes.
PRUE:  He was very lucky.
Yeah, very lucky.
PAUL:  Wow. Thank you, Kate.
Good luck.  Thank you.
Going in. Right.
The bakers now face
a multitasking nightmare.
Rotate when it comes to, like,
six minutes.
Every single biscuit should be
baked to the same colour
and texture.
I have to watch them like a hawk.
I don't want them
to get too much colour.
But with 48 to perfect
in the remaining time...
Oh, no.  ..and only one oven...
I'm only going to put one at a time.
..they'll now have to perfectly
time their brakes
and prepare new batches
for the oven...
..simultaneously.
It should be quite tight.
It should've been in the oven, like,
20 minutes ago.  Nine minutes.
12.
SHE SPEAKS IN RUSSIAN
When it is a stressful atmosphere,
I can't count in English.
Watch them burn.
Yep.
Another couple of minutes.
I hate feeling like I'm not going
to be ready for something.
BEEPING
At any point,
they can slightly over bake.
The reason why rotate them
is so that they can get, like,
an even bake.
Oh, look at them babies!
Going to do another two batches.
A little bit longer.
SHE BLOWS RASPBERRIES
Better give them another
two minutes.  Ta-dah!
OK.
Bakers, you've got 30 minutes left,
30 minutes.
I want them to be a bit more golden.
I just need them to cool now,
really quick.
The filling is so soft
that any sort of heat on it
will just melt it,
and the sandwich will fall apart.
They're perfect.
They're a bit dark.
Just got to really concentrate.
I can't afford to drop any.
Eek!
Oh...!  One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight...
Two, four, six, eight, ten.
Two, two, two, one.
Right. Here goes.
Let the squeezing commence.
Just starting to assemble them now.
Trying to do it as quickly as I can
without mucking up.
This is the worst bit, isn't it?
The last ten minutes. You can
feel the panic around the room.
It's not quite even, but I think
that's quite a nice amount.
I'm filling them 7g at a time.
People are sitting at home going,
"Who does that?"
Not good. In a bit of a rush.
I just thought I was going
to have more time than this.
Should I put more gin in?
I just want to taste it.
Oh, yeah, go for it.
You are always licking my chocolate.
SHE GASPS
Sex, isn't it?
Orange and... Sex?  Well done!
I wasn't getting sex,
but I was looking at you, Chris.
But maybe for that filling, I'd be
on the turn for you.  Good Lord!
You never know.
Fiddly.
I feel as if I should've used
all the time up.
The problem is,
of having a bit of time to spare,
you probably feel a bit nervous.
I feel as if I should've gone
over them a bit more.
There we go. Steady hands.
Steady hands.  Oh!
That, James, is a thing of beauty.
Paul is a little bit
scared of the glitter.
I think he should try and embrace
it, do you know what I mean?#
We should be making him up
like David Bowie.
Ah, bum, bum, bum.
I've got on the jelly.
My hands are shaking so much.
Three, six, nine, 12...
19, 20, 21, 22, 23, 24.  24!
You've got one minute,
one minute left!
Do they have to be on the plate?
I've just run out of time, I'm not
going to have time to ice them all.
Do you want a hand?
Yes, please, please, please, please.
I will be as careful as I can.
It's OK.
If they fall apart, they fall apart.
My hands are shaking so much.
Don't worry.
Two, four, six, eight, ten, 11, 12.
Five, six, seven, eight...
It keeps getting lopsided.
There you go. You're going to do it,
you're going to do it.
Bakers, you've got ten seconds!
Two...
Time up, I'm afraid, bakers.
Please put your sandwich biscuits
at the end of your benches.
Thank you, guys.
Tom, don't touch.
I'm just straightening them up.
No touching.
Want to try mine?
They are so good. That is sick.
That's really nice.
It's judgment time for the
signature sandwich biscuits.
Hi, Liam.  Hello.
All uniform.  Nice.
All the same colour, and there's 24.
Tick, tick, tick.  So far.
Right, let's have a look.
Gosh, they are a bit squishy.
Got it, totally got it.
I'll just stand here and catch
Paul Hollywood's drippings.
That's actually what's
happening here.
But I think, from a flavour point of
view, they're very interesting.
You get a malt kick.  Yes!  Coffee
kick.  Yes, yeah.  It's really good.
But this is a meal.
I think they're too chunky.  Yeah.
"See me." That's what it says
on the bottom of your work.
You've made 24 almost-identical
biscuits.
Very delicious.
I'm getting vanilla. Certainly
getting rhubarb, which is lovely.
I didn't get the custard,
but it's vanilla,
so you're giving that sensation
of rhubarb and custard.
But the quality of the biscuit
is fantastic.
Very rich, bitter chocolate.
The whisky is... Wow, it's coming
through at the end.
Yeah, beautiful, isn't it?
Do you know? I think it's too much.
It's got the concentration of
a chocolate truffle.  Oh, OK.
They do look absolutely
perfectly even.
Oh, sorry about that, bit oozy.
No denying the banana...
And peanut.  If the cream filling
would have set,
it would have been a fantastic
biscuit.
It does look very intriguing.
Filling looks a little squashy.
Your biscuit is quite hard.
I think you've worked that too much.
Think so?  Yeah.  There's no gin
flavour, but I think
the flavour is wonderful,
especially the raspberry jam.
I love that chewy middle,
and it is still quite crisp outside.
The only issue is the slightly
irregular sizes.
Yeah.  But the flavours and the
texture of the almond and the coffee
together, and the slight chewiness
in the bite, perfect.  Thank you.
The icing's a little bit dodgy,
isn't it?  Very dodgy.
It's so tough, it's offering me out
for a fight.
It is too tough.
A story of two halves.
The pineapple's there.
Delicious flavour, yum.
I think they look amazing.
Thank you.  You've got consistency.
I think they look very
neatly-filled.
I'm almost a little bit concerned
about that amount of glitter.
Tastes great.  Thank you.
Crispy on the outside, soft and
cookie-like on the inside,
and the marshmallow's set
beautifully so when you bite in,
it doesn't pour out.  And in fact,
with fluff, like that, which is
pure sugar, it's clever not to
have the biscuit too sweet.
As a sandwich biscuit, you've ticked
all the boxes. Well done.
Thank you.
They're dancing biscuits.
Aren't they? Yeah, look at them!
Boi-oi-oing, boi-oi-oing!
HE CHUCKLES
That's great, that!
They're a little bit scruffy.
Very different, but because
everything's a bit strong,
it's too much.  You have this mix
of rose water and cardamom which
isn't particularly pleasant, but
very daring of you to do it there.
And the most fun we've had so far.
Oh?  Yeah, I'm just going to do that
one more time.
That's just lovely.
It's quite incredible.  Yeah.
You were asked for 24 absolutely
identical biscuits
and I think you might have hit it.
They look incredible.
Sharp, nice, clean lines,
distinction between the two sides.
Bit of drippage.
That's delicious! Can't really taste
the limoncello. You just get
a beautiful citrus flavour.
Beautifully-cooked, very tart.
What's not to like? It's wonderful.
Thank you, thanks so much.
I like the look of them!
I think the bake's good.
I think the size is good.
Tell us about the filling?
The chocolate one is just a
chocolate ganache.
The central one is coffee
and amaretto.
The cream's very rich in chocolate.
The amaretto flavour is delicious.
The biscuit, though, is a triumph.
Thank you.  Never mind about running
out of time.
I did it! There was 24.  Bravo.
Finish on the word triumph, Tom,
and don't... Stop speaking.
Stop speaking. Save triumph.
I feel good! Yes!
I don't want to get too excited,
but that has given me a boost
that I needed. I would have liked it
if Paul got glitter
all over his face.
OK, brilliant, I can breathe.
I'm trying to use different flavours
in everything I'm making,
and I keep getting it wrong!
Last week, it was good bake,
improve on flavours.
This week, good flavours,
just texture was wrong.
Can I not just marry the two,
and it'll be fine?
The bakers could practise for their
Signature Challenge, but now,
they'll have no idea what biscuit
they'll be asked to bake next.
Time for your Technical Challenge,
which has been set for you by Paul!
Any advice, Paul?
Don't fold under the pressure.
Well, that covers the whole of it,
right. Off you two pop!
Off we pop.  Right, Paul would like
you to make 12 fortune cookies,
six almond cookies,
and six orange patterned cookies.
Each cookie must contain
a fortune inside.
No idea how that works, but I'm sure
you've got the mad skills.
You've got two hours to complete
this challenge.
On your marks... Get set...
BOTH: Bake!  Oh, my God.
The bakers all have
identical ingredients and
the same basic recipe.
If we have a Chinese take away,
we often get fortune cookies,
so I've got a good sense of
how to shape them.
I've seen them on TV and stuff,
and, like, films and that.
Funnily enough, I nearly made
fortune cookies a while back,
and I thought,
"Nah, that's too much of a faff!"
And I didn't do it! Argh!
Paul? Fortune cookies.  On paper,
you think, "That's very easy."
Bit actually, this is a very
difficult Technical Challenge.
You have an almond flavour
and you have an orange flavour.
They have a little pattern.
Now this is all about timing.
You can't put all of them into the
oven at the same time.
Two and three at a time, possibly,
no more than that,
and it must just brown
on the outside.
And when they come out, you only
have a very short period of time to
create that fortune cookie shape
before they set.
So it's all speed and dexterity?
But the killer thing is snap.
Yeah, it breaks.
It says, "You will be working with
a man with blue eyes."
There you go, you see?
Well, that means I keep my job till
tomorrow, at least. Good.
The first instruction is to write
12 fortunes.
What are you supposed to write?
NOEL: "Look after your feet,
and the rest will follow."
I like that.
"Speak your mind, for it is..."
Stupid.  I do them as I go along,
unless I think of a funny one.
Can I read one?  What, in the
beginning? Of course, they're all
pretty much the same.
"Make it count." "Keep on smiling."
Yes!  I like these.
They're quite punchy.
"Make it count." You've gone for
"make it count" again.
Because you should really
make it count, you see?
You should really make it count.
It says, uh, mix the
egg whites, oil, and water.
Ahh!
I shouldn't look at other people,
just do what I'm doing.
They need to be light, but they
don't need much air.
People are using mixers.
I'm guessing this'll be like a
twill-like consistency, so
spreadable, but not too runny.
Looks a little lacklustre.
And then divide the batter into two.
Form two circles of almond butter.
How big is a fortune cookie, though?
No idea.
Probably a teaspoon of mixture,
and just smooth it round.
Just try it with one.
I know they're supposed to be thin.
Absolutely no idea how long to put
these in for.
I am very nervous at the moment.
We're going in.  I'm going to start
with three minutes.
That seems a lucky Chinese number,
I guess?
I'm going to go for
lucky five minutes.
I'm going to sit here
and monitor this.
Slightly golden, OK.
I thought they'd be done like that,
but actually, they're quite
slow to cook, because it's
quite a low oven temperature.
Take the first one out.
Going in. Think they're too thick.
"Once baked, place a fortune in the
centre and seal."
Ohh! I wish I had asbestos fingers!
Ooh!  Super-hard.
You have to work quite quick.
WHISPERING:  I don't know what's
happened to it.
That folds like that.
"Seal using the rim of a glass."
Put it over a glass and shape?
It's as simple as that!
That's it, yeah.
SHE SIGHS
So I'm going to put a fortune in,
fold them in half, and then I'm just
squishing it at the edge to give it
that line underneath.
And they're not sticking.
What's that for?  Because it'll
set off quite hard.
I'll just put it in there
so they don't fold out too much.
It's like origami, isn't it?
Yeah.  I love how you don't panic.
Is everyone else panicking?
Can you not feel it?  No, not really.
That's why I like being at the back.
Yeah, there's panic happening.  OK.
I didn't expect them to get hard
as fast as they do.
You've got to be really,
really quick.
They just crack,
as you've just seen.
They look like real cookies
and everything!
It's just not right.
I'm trying to create a shape
and I just can't get a shape.
Ooh, you're cracking on me.
...the hell is this?
That looks more like a Cornish
pasty.
That's not a fortune cookie shape
in the slightest.
There's my two. I just can't do it.
I've only made two.  Got ten to go.
I can't, can't, can't give up now.
OK, put some more in.  Just putting
it in.  Come on, you babies.
Give me some bread, give me some
pastry, give me something...
wholesome. Fortune cookies.
On the almond ones, I need to melt
some chocolate and chop up some
hazelnuts.  Very lovely.
Give that some...  That one's a
disaster.  Oh, why?
Yeah, there's me fortune cookie.
Give that a really good bash.
That'll make you feel better.
I know.  That's it!
OK! Now you're laughing!
Mine aren't going brown.
That's about there.
OK, they'll get cold very, very
quickly.
So it says press to seal, but then
it says use the rim of the glass.
What if it goes like that,
then like that?
They're just so rubbery.
Do you want to put an apron on,
and have a go?  No.
Oh, man! I'm so doing these for
my next dinner party!
Ohh, so frustrating!
They're poor.  Tell you what,
let's read one of these,
see if you can get any advice from
your own advice.
You dance great.
Has that helped you any?
Bakers, you've got one hour left!
I'm gonna flavour
the orange one now.
So that's got orange essence and
orange colouring in, as well.
I don't like using too much
food dye. It tastes all
synthetic and horrible.
Orange circle... Looks more like a
fried egg, if the yolk split.
Dot, dot, dot, dot, dot...
Oh, yeah, cos this works.
"Create pattern from the dots, using
a cocktail toothpick."
So I'm cracking into the middle.
The idea was to make it
look like segments.
I'm just going to put these in...
No, it's a disgrace.
Bakers, you've got half an hour
left!
They're so bad.
This is the last batch going in.
The orange could be a little bit
stronger.
I did it! Did it, that's it.
-Ish, -ish!
So how the hell did I do it?
Have I got time? Uh, "dip almond
cookies in melted chocolate,
"and coat with chopped,
toasted hazelnuts."
Last batch coming out.
Bakers, you've got 15 minutes left!
Oh, my God! Only managed
to make five.
And this will be it.
I'm going to see if I can do
another two.
We're doing that. These aren't
quite cooked, these ones.
One, two, three, four, five, yeah.
Hold up.  I'm not good at
Technicals at all, man.
All I have to do now is the dipping
and the nutting.
Bakers, that's the end of your
Technical Challenge!
Well, I'm going to get
annihilated here.
Chin up.  I'm going.  No, you're not.
Please, bring your fortune
cookies up, and place them
behind your photos.
Paul and Prue are expecting
12 perfectly-shaped,
crisp fortune cookies and
they won't know whose is whose.
Come on.  OK.
They've got the shape to them.
And they're actually quite even.
That cracked beautifully.
It says, "Keep smiling."
I can taste the almond.
And I can taste the orange.
Moving on, they are pretty even.
There is a shape.
However, these are
a little bit rubbery.
No crack. That one
is absolutely delicious.
They're just slightly underdone.
Yeah.  Moving on. There is not enough
colouring in there at all.
It cracks well.
You could break your teeth on them.
They're a bit thick.
I don't think they ever got to the
oven, did they?
Raw batter's not much fun.
OK, moving on. All look the same,
orange needs to be a stronger
colour.  That really cracked nicely.
Nice orange flavour, just needed
more colour in there.
OK, they are quite raw. The almond
ones have lost their shape,
and you can unfold them.
They don't really snap.
They're just not baked enough.
These look pretty good!  The orange
one has got a stronger colour,
which I like. Nice break.
Got a nice flavouring.
That's a rather good one.
Now, these look good. Do you know?
I think they're very beautiful.
That is a very good little heart.
Oh, its crack is
a little bit rubbery.
Are we going to say this? "Today,
you will mostly poo candyfloss."
Well, they have followed
that up with,
"You will get bored
of writing fortunes."
Nice orange flavour, as well.
Yeah. Oh, this is not
a very happy picture.
I don't think they were quite ready.
They haven't managed to seal it up
before they bend it.
Oh, beautiful, crack! But they
aren't the right shape, are they?
No. Right, moving on to whatever
these are.
I've made a right mess of this.
I think he just invented that.
They're raw.  Although, I am getting
the almond flavour in there.
Moving on. Uh, the orange ones
look quite pretty.
That's got a bit of a cylindrical
shape to it before it's been bent.
Start with this.
Ooh, broke very well.
Very good.  The almond's coming
through nicely. It is crispy.  Mmm.
Nice flavour in there, nice.
Very good.
"Prue and Paul will now
rank the fortune cookies
"from the worst to the best."
In 11th place is this one.
Whose is this?  Me.
I had a little bit of a struggle.
Tenth place, we have this one.
Oh, Flo. They're the wrong shape,
aren't they?
Ninth spot is this one.
That's me.  They are raw.
Yeah, I just couldn't get my head
around the whole shape.
"Kate is eighth. Liam is seventh.
Stephen is six, Tom fifth,
"and Julia is fourth."
In third spot is this one. Nice
shape, and nice pattern as well.
Nice snap. Well done.  Thank you.
This is excellent. Who's number two?
Sophie, they look
absolutely beautiful.
In first place, obviously,
is this one.
Nice colour, nice shape.
You ticked all the boxes.
Before I left, my brother said to
come back number one Technical,
or don't come back at all.
That's what he said!
Prue and Paul's comments were
probably quite fair.
However, when they spat them out...
Well, that did hurt a little.
Paul read out, "I've made a right
mess of this."
He got that right, anyway!
I also wrote, "I'm never
baking these again."
Which is true, that will come true.
SANDI: One final biscuit
challenge remains
and it's a first for
The Great British Bake Off.
Morning, bakers.
Welcome to your
Showstopper Challenge.
OK, I think this is going to be
one of my absolute favourites.
We are so excited.
This is some Willy Wonka
stuff right now.
Today, you're going to be
making biscuit board games.
It needs to be at least
40 centimetres in diameter,
it needs to have at
least eight elements.
The biscuits can be
any flavour or any type
but the main thing is you must
be able to play your board game
and then eat your board game.
Yeah, preferably in that order.
It's not going to work
the other way round.
You've got three-and-a-half hours.
On your marks...  Get set...
Bake!
NOEL:  Creating a functioning
board game from biscuits
is the ultimate test
of the bakers' ability
to create stunning biscuits
on a grand scale for their boards
whilst also delivering exquisitely
detailed biscuit playing pieces.
PAUL:  You've got to be a designer.
You've got to be very artistic
to really highly decorate
the biscuits and the players.
PRUE:  Board games are
all about the detail
so it's got to be very neat.
The colours must be sharp edged,
the writing must be legible.
PAUL:  You could create the most
amazing board game in the world
but, actually, it's got to taste
good. This is the Bake Off.
Time today is so tight.
There's no room for error.
I've got to get three doughs
done in about half an hour
otherwise the game
won't be finished.
Hopefully I can get everything
baked in the first two hours.
I've got like an hour to decorate,
which would be chill.
NOEL:  Every dough will
need to result in a biscuit
that's robust enough to hold
its shape when it's played with...
In practice, it hasn't gone well.
The biscuits have crumbled a lot.
..while still delivering a
texture that's a pleasure to eat.
When I rehearsed this, I demolished
about a quarter of the chequerboard
in about 30 minutes,
so  I  thought it tasted OK.
SANDI: Sophie is making a simple
Snakes and Ladders board,
but it requires 50
individual chocolate biscuits
and another 50 flavoured
with lemon and bergamot.
So, have you done this before?
Sort of. "Sort of"?
What does that mean?
I've not done beginning to end
timed or anything like that.
And your Snakes and Ladders,
how are you going to show us them?
They are all going to
be royal icing flooded,
So pipe the outline and then
flood it with royal icing.
I like the idea of the flavours.
I think the lemon, the chocolate,
and the bergamot is going
to give it a nice, little kick.
You seem to be under control.
That's because I've no idea
what my timings should be.
LAUGHTER
Ignorance is bliss.
NOEL:  When it comes
to Snakes and Ladders,
Sophie won't be playing alone.
I'm doing the architect's take.
It's Drains and Ladders.
The board itself is going to
be made to look like a house.
Tom will need to find time to
cover a cinnamon and nutmeg board
in fondant, spray paint it and pipe
numbers, ladders and drainpipes,
and make chocolate and
peppermint playing pieces.
Did you design it
on a drawing board?
I did. It's a bit childlike.
Shall we call it naive?
Let's call it naive.  It's naive.
Do you think you've nailed
your timing?  Not at all.
You're just a free spirit.
Time, who needs it?  Who needs it?
Who needs that sort of construct?
If Paul and Prue say
"You ran out of time,"
say, "What does time mean?"
SANDI: For James,
this Showstopper Challenge is
a chance to go back in time.
The baked is based on an
old board game called Coppit.
My wife got the board game
when she was four.
It's been in the family ever since,
so it's one that's in our games
cupboard that comes out regularly.
James is making a board
from spiced orange, chocolate
and ginger shortbread
and he'll colour more spiced
orange dough for his playing pieces.
In the winter, we play a board
game on a Saturday night
and it's always Coppit that
the kids want to get out.
So, it gets quite competitive
especially with the two
boys playing it as well.
NOEL:  Stacey's biscuit board game
also has a strong family connection
but it's never been played before.
I made up a game called
Get To School
because there's all the
challenges of getting them to school
and all the things they've got
to do and things they forget.
You're always shouting at them.
Only a mum would
come up with this game.
Players have to move across a
fondant-covered, chocolate board
to try and win a
good boy star biscuit
featuring Stacey's sons'
favourite flavours.
I'm doing a plain chocolate biscuit,
cos my kids love that,
and then I'm doing breakfast
based vanilla and strawberry.
I'm using freeze dried strawberries.
The thing about freeze dried
strawberries, they are strong.
I really wanted to make sure
you could taste the strawberry
and I think you can.
While Stacey has gone with
classic, everyday flavours,
Kate's risking everything
on an obscure ingredient
she's found in one
of her history books.
These are grains of paradise.
They're, like, an ancient spice
that's been, like, long forgotten.
It takes kind of like gin.
Grains of paradise
will flavour Kate's board
and orange and cardamom
playing pieces
will complete a game inspired by
another period of ancient history -
the 1990s.
This is my Jumanji board game.
It's like one of my favourite
films from when I was small
and a lot of animals come
out of the board game.
I admire the fact that you're using
something slightly different -
grains of paradise.
Also the orange and cardamom.
Two fascinating flavours. If it
works together with the board...
It's about getting
the time to decorate.
He was fussy about the icing
on your Signature biscuits,
so just bear it in mind.
Flo is hoping her choice of game
can kick-start her
recovery in biscuit week.
It's a take on Operation.
I don't do nothing easy so
I'll have a go at that one.
Flo's Almond biscuit patient
will lie on a vanilla
biscuit operating table
and everything will be
covered in coloured fondant
she's chosen to make herself.
I'm going to put borders
round it in red
and then the man's in,
like, a flesh colour.
And I'm hoping I've got time
to put a pair of shorts on him.
Not looking for a lot, am I?
THEY LAUGH
It sounds really complicated.
Bring it on. "Bring it on."
Getting the game's board
baked early is crucial.
I need to get a crack on if I want
to get my middle triangle bits done.
Not only will these giant
biscuits need to cool completely
before they can be iced...
Mine is about decorating
and I can't do that if I
don't have a board to work on.
..the bakers will also need to
quickly free up their ovens
for all the other biscuit components
that will ensure their
games are playable.
Just have to go like the
clappers when it comes out.
NOEL:  Whilst Sophie's simple
Snakes and Ladders board
is proving complicated...
I need to get this
bit as nice as I can.
..Julia's simple board's...
I think yes.
..is for a game that has a pretty
straightforward explanation.
My game is...
A British Baking Game.
Julia's ginger and lime board
will have a path of chocolate and
orange liqueur stepping stones.
Whoever lands on and eats
the most Star Baker biscuits
is her Bake Off winner.
Making my own game,
I was just hoping to be original
and show that I can be creative.
But Julia's creation may
not be that original.
My board game's called
Adventures In Bakeland.
Yan's lemon and matcha tea
orange and cardamom biscuit squares
will lead the winning player
to a biscuit Sandi and Noel.
Because it's going
to be a chequerboard,
they spread ever so slightly
so I'm going to put them
a little spaced apart,
bake them and then
they come together.
Bakers, you are halfway through the
time for your biscuit board game.
God.
How long have you
been standing there?
Slightly too long.  I hate that.
Thanks.
JULIA HUMS
NOEL:  Even with the largest
items in the oven...
this Showstopper is
about to get much harder.
I'm making the good boy stars.
They're very soft today.
They're not usually as soft as this.
There are now hundreds
of intricate and fragile
biscuit playing pieces to complete.
Now I need to hurry up.
That's Sandy and Noel.
I've nailed him.
When I make my little hats,
I put about ten grams of
biscuit into the bottom
and cook them that way up.
but I have to oil them well
otherwise they won't come out.
SANDI: Liam doesn't have just one
set of playing pieces to make...
he has three.  I've designed
a multifunctional board game.
So, if you want to play Noughts
& Crosses, you can play that.
If you want to play Snakes and
Ladders, you can play that.
You can play Draughts.
How many pieces are
you bringing to this?
Oh, I've got loads.
Liam's classroom games compendium
will feature a chocolate
orange shortbread blackboard
and over 30 individual
playing pieces
full of flavours straight from
his family's recipe book.
Because my nan always
believed in remedies and stuff,
whenever I was ill, I always
had lemon, ginger and honey.
That's my biscuit.
To make us feel better.
Just a little bit.  Right, OK.
After my fortune cookies.
THEY LAUGH
NOEL:  Whilst he's only
making one game...
Measuring out all the pieces that
are going to sit on top of the map.
..Chris' individual biscuits
will have to represent
the whole of Great Britain.
I apologise to Cornwall now.
I think I've chopped them off.
Chris' rum and ginger pieces
will sit on an orange
and cardamom biscuit board
to create a game that fuels
his nautical ambitions.
I'm making a Great British Sail Off.
I'm going to have a seal, a dolphin,
I'll put a few land mounts
on Stonehenge, Big Ben, etc.
Instead of a dice,
I've gone for a compass.
You spin it. Whatever number
determines how far you go.
It is quite a big board game.
You're trying to create a
lot of different shapes.
Have you made this before?
Not in three-and-a-half hours.
I need nearer six.
So, as long as the judges
don't keep me talking too long,
I might just do it.  OK.
So, one more question...
HE GROANS
I'm kidding.
SANDI: Steven's Showstopper
will see him attempt to make more
playing pieces than anyone else.
I made it the other day and,
just as I was doing it,
I thought, "This is insane,
what have you done to yourself?"
Of course it's too late by then.
He's planned an entire
coffee gingerbread chess set
complete with a Union Jack-coloured
spiced orange biscuit board.
32 chess pieces, 3-D biscuits.
3-D biscuits?  3-D biscuits.
And each one will have a
different fondant top.
How many pieces are
you having to make then?
100 individual pieces.
That's a lot of work.
SANDI: 90 minutes remaining.
Perfect.
I just want to check that I've
done all the pieces I need to do.
Alarm clock, toothbrush,
blazer, school.
I'm going to check it
every five minutes
cos some of the pieces
are smaller than the others.
I'm, like, massively
behind timings right now.
I'm making fondant, very sticky job.
SHE GROANS
It just takes icing sugar upon
icing sugar to get it right.
I'm not making my own fondant.
I figured I'd rather finish
and use shop-bought.
These are little
individual cupcakes, pawns.
This is the slow, fiddly bit.
I have got a lot to do.
So, I'm starting my black
chalkboard royal icing.
It's getting there.
It's a terrible job, this.
I hate it.
A couple of them are
slightly overbaked.
This is going to be the compass.
12, 14.
Biscuits are still cooking.
Because it is so crumbly
when I've moved it, crackage.
Not as bad as my last one, which
had literally all shattered.
Ahh!
My base broke.
It's all cracked.
Aw. Is she OK?
There's fondant going over it.
Might be a nightmare but
I'll have a go.
SHE SIGHS
Bakers, you've got one hour left.
So, I'm just going to start icing.
Need some fondant to
make a sea effect.
I thought I'd do this first so
at least I've got a decent board.
I've got two white sides,
two blue sides.
There's a bit of a gap.
I can fix it.
Maybe I'll just leave it rustic.
How does a Union Jack work?
Right... White, white, white.
So, I'm just setting up these gates
so when I spray my roof,
the red doesn't bleed all
over the rest of the board.
This is going to be the
main part of my board.
Just trying to get
variation in colour.
This just takes time.
It takes a lot of filling in.
HE SIGHS
I feel really nervous about this.
HE EXHALES
Shaking so much.
Just royal icing the black sections.
This is hot, granulated sugar
so it just holds them in place.
Ahh!
Don't know my own
strength sometimes.
Let's see if they come out.
As long as you just play it
just there, we're good.
That's it, can't move it
round the board at all.  Yeah.
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
I know it doesn't look like much,
these are going to get spray gunned.
Doing the monkeys.
It needs to be really precise
but I haven't got time.
There's just something innocent
about them not being decorated.
Oh!
I've just literally
sprayed that all over the...
HE GROANS
I need to be so much
further ahead than this.
I'm quite far behind,
so I need to glue them
together and then start piping.
My game is supposed to
be a little bit playful,
so if it's not really
neat, then it's OK.
That's my story anyway
and I'm sticking to it.
Bakers, you only have
five minutes left.
HE EXHALES
This is me stressed.
Oh, I've got so much to do.
I've still got to do my
drainpipes and everything.
Like a duck, graceful underneath.
This is probably the hardest
thing I've ever done in my life.
This challenge.  I don't know
if I'll finish on time.
Oh, my God. This is terrible.
It is not the Showstopper.
I'm running out of time.
Anything I can help with?
It depends. I don't know what
your piping skills are like.
They're powerful.  Are they?
I'm known as the Powerful Piper.
I had to rush to
get it done in time.
One minute.
Six, one, two, five.
OK, bakers, your time is up.
SHE GROANS
God, I'm so unhappy
with that, but whatever.
Looks like a bomb's hit it.
It's judgment time for the
bakers' Showstoppers.
Sophie, please bring up your
biscuit board game.
Well, I must say,
it's very beautifully neat.
You haven't had to ice
the whole thing.
The blocks all look equal.
Dice look very good.
Beautiful dice.
I think we need to try some of this.
Love the lemon flavour. Bergamot.
Afterwards, you get...  There's
a little bit right at the end.
OK, yeah.  But it works,
it's beautiful, crispy, snap.
Snakes and ladders is a classic game
and I think you've done a very,
very good job.
That was a lot better
than I expected.
Well done.
I love the colours.
Bright as anything. The edges
are terrific, it's very neat.
The board is a mixed spice.
Very spicy and Christmassy.
And soft. As a biscuit, that's too
soft for me.
But the overall design is fantastic.
Very much an architect's piece
of work.
The overall game
is a little disappointing.
Yeah.  The biscuits are delicious.
Aren't they?  There's not much ginger
coming through,
but there's lots of lime. Texture is
very, very good, as well.
You make your way around the board
towards Noel and Sandi.
It's a shame all this is broken up,
cos what you've essentially done
is made a lot of different biscuits
and piped different numbers on them.
The lemony one's lovely.  The
biscuit's been overworked, slightly.
It's quite rubbery. The matcha comes
through, that's pretty much it.
James, I love the colours.
I mean, they're my kind of colours.
They're bang in your face.
Exactly.  I really love them.
Cones have sort of worked.
Every time I move it, a little bit
more falls off.
Is that part of the game?
It has to be a quick game.
I must say the texture
is nice to eat.
The chocolate's delicious, melts in
the mouth, the flavour's very good.
The actual board game, the way
you've set it up, is a nice idea.
Thank you.
Flo, please bring up
your biscuit board game.
Do I have to?  Yes.
That's Mr Neverwell.
I'm not surprised.
LAUGHTER
So you pick these up...  Yeah.
..and you try and pick up one
of these things here.  Yeah.
Very good. It certainly
looks striking.
But it is a bit messy, isn't it?
You made your fondant, didn't you?
Yeah.  And you didn't need to.
No. The man's almond.
The yellow one is vanilla.
There's not a lot of difference
between them.
Not a lot of difference
between the two.
They're both great biscuits, they're
crumbly, they break easily,
there's no chew to it at all.
Simplistic, but actually
it does the job.
Well done, Flo.
He's getting bin bagged.
I'll have to sedate.
You spin the compass, and depending
on which number it lands on,
is how many spaces
you move.
That works quite well, doesn't it?
It's a bit rough and ready.
It's colourful,
which is a good thing.
And the little boats are quite neat.
The landmark is rum and ginger.
That's Scotland leaving England.
LAUGHTER
You do want your own teeth,
I'll just tell you.
Both the biscuits are burnt.
The flavour's OK.
I think the most impressive thing
is your compass.
No-one's ever said that
to me before.
Not your strong point, then.
LAUGHTER
I think it does look a little bit
messy.
I just didn't have time to, like,
decorate it in the way I wanted to.
I think it looks a little bit more
like a jungle swamp.
That's the lemon and paradise one.
I'm not getting the grains
of paradise.
I can't taste it. It's a little bit
solid. I don't think eating that is
going to be a huge pleasure.
It looks a bit unfinished, because
once the board was done,
you just spent the rest of the time
cutting out these shapes.
You could've decorated them a
little bit more.
Fantastic flavour.  The lemon, honey,
and ginger is delicious.
To get the honey,
the lemon, and ginger altogether
is quite tricky to do.
The board game is a chocolate orange
and cinnamon.
And it's got chocolate chips in it?
Mmm-hmm.
I have to say, I think
it's absolutely delicious.
It's just crumbly and melting
and yum.
I'd like to see more decoration,
but the biscuits are the star
of the show.
Which game do you want to play?
Noughts and crosses.
OK, you be the noughts.
OK, cool.
You could've won.  I know, I know.
Paul!
I would never do that.
LAUGHTER
Well done.
We're getting drunk tonight.
Steven, would you like to bring
your biscuit board game up?
I think I'm going to help.
This is a bit scary.
LAUGHTER
OK.
That is exceptional.  Thank you.
The work that you've got on the top
is sublime.
It's very delicate.
It's a little masterpiece.
You have a great bake.
It's a great tasting gingerbread.
It's very good because the fondant
isn't too thick.
The orange flavour is delicious.
It's very well designed, and it's as
neat as a pin.
Very, very clever.
Well done, Stephen.  Thank you.
Well done.  Oh, mate.
Stacey, please bring
up your biscuit board game.
The board game is a made-up game
called Get To School.
There's three players,
I've got three boys.
It is so neat, and so beautifully
done. The piping is good,
and the sweet little school blazer
is just exquisite.
That's vanilla and strawberry.
Slightly chewy.  Yeah.
Quite rubbery.
Sorry.  I'm not getting much flavour.
From an eating point of view,
that's much more icing than you need
on that bit of biscuit.
The chocolate, dry as a bone,
the texture's all wrong.
It just crumbles into nothing.
It's a beautifully conceived game,
but the flavour and the texture
is not so wonderful.
Do you not think we look like four
people who'd couldn't agree
what game they wanted to play?
So we cut them all into bits.
I loved this challenge.
I mean, an incredible array
of imagination on display.
Absolutely, and some terrific skill,
too.  Steven's was exquisite.
And then Tom's, I mean, that could
have come out of a magazine.
It's the same
when you look at Sophie's
and the taste of those
biscuits were divine.
Chris came into the
Showstopper in trouble.
His problem was that he just
never got near the end.
Stacey's, although they look great,
the biscuits were bone dry
and her cake struggled as well.
She didn't finish her bake.
She's too ambitious.
Flo didn't do brilliantly today and
she was not pleased with herself.
So it's not as clean-cut
as you think
when you look down at the bottom.
That's going to be more of
a conversation, who's going.
But I think we'll agree
on who's Star Baker.
I think so.
That's my head!  I know.
I'm short enough.
Well, bakers, thank you
for some wonderful board games.
I've got the lovely job of
announcing Star Baker.
The Star Baker this week
produced some exquisite
detail in the Showstopper.
The Star Baker is
Steven.
APPLAUSE
So, of course, that means
I have the difficult
job of announcing who
is going to be leaving us.
The baker leaving the tent is...
..Chris.  Aw! What a surprise.
Come on, let's have a hug. Come on.
APPLAUSE
I'm disappointed I never got to make
any breads, any pastries,
the things that
fit my style of baking.
I'm just so honoured and privileged
to have got in that tent.
Everything fell to pieces for him.
It's a real shame, you know, cos
he's got some fantastic ideas.
All right, mate. Well done.
Everybody will miss Chris.
It's one of the sad things about
Bake Off, is seeing people go.
Are you happy to get through?
Just a little bit.
Gulp!
Dodged a bullet there but,
yeah, happy that.
You turned out all right,
didn't you?
THEY LAUGH
It's all right.
It's all right.  All right?
I'm not disappointed I didn't get
Star Baker. Maybe another week.
The double.
Oh, you're going for a double.
No, I mean, he's done the double.
I don't think I'll ever get
used to this feeling.
It's alien to me.
I've bullied myself so much
all my life that finally I'm getting
praise, I don't know what
to do with it.
This week, I let myself
down terrible.
I expected to go home.
Come here.
You're not getting rid of me
that easy, are you?
Next time...  We expect
perfection.  ..it's a bread week.
No pressure.
But who will impress Paul...
I feel like you're trying to psych
me out.  ..with a fruity signature...
Ah, they've sunk!  I don't think it's
baked.  No, that's not good.
..a two-tiered technical...
Oh, my God.
..that's all about the detail...
The bottom of my bread has eaten
the top.  ..and the most ambitious...
This is where the trouble starts.
..multicoloured bread sculptures
the Bake Off has ever seen.
That is ridiculous.
Subtitles by Ericsson